ladies and gentlemen I'm most honored to
be here today with the ceremony to mark
the signing between the European Union
and Belarus oh the visa facilitation
agreement and agreement on the admission
of persons residing without
authorization this agreement have been
10 years in the making
they were first envisaged at the 2009
Eastern Partnership summit facilitating
the issuing of visas to citizens of the
European Union and valorous on a basis
of reciprocity was seen by the European
Union as a way to promote mobility but
also to facilitate people-to-people
contacts which in turn Foster's the
development of economic humanitarian
cultural scientific and other ties the
negotiations of the visa facilitation
agreement with the Republic of Belarus
we're formally opened in Brussels in
June 2014
visa statistics give evidence of the
strong ties between Belarus and the
European Union in 2018 the number of
Schengen visa applications in Joris
reached almost 700,000 around 83% of the
visa issued our multiple entry visas
Belarus is a country with one of the
highest number of Schengen visas
delivered per capita in the world and
has one of the lowest visa refusal rates
against this background the conclusion
of a visa facilitation agreement can
therefore represent a saw it
improvement of Belarus citizens mobility
towards the European Union the visa fee
for processing applications will be set
at 35 euros with some categories
benefiting from a full waiver of the
visa fee the documents to be presented
will be simplified for quite many
categories of applicants and simplified
criteria for issuing multiple entry
visas will be applicable in addition our
diplomats and the EU LeSabre
stakeholders will be able to travel
visa-free this agreement goes
hand-in-hand with the fundamental
principles governing the cooperation
between the parties as well as the
obligations and responsibilities
including the respect of human rights
and democratic principles this is an
important element for the European Union
and the same time is true for the
readmission agreement there is another
element that is important for the
European Union we will not be able to
conclude the visa facilitation agreement
unless the Commission makes a positive
assessment of the security and integrity
of belorus system of issuance of
biometric diplomatic passports Belarus
has recently shared a specimen of the
new biometric passports and European
Union is assessing it and we hope for a
rapid conclusion of this process finish
the Bakke Commissioner Johansson the
visa facilitation agreement will mark a
milestone in the relations between our
people the ties between our societies
are already strong through the erasmus+
programme - joint exchanges training and
volunteering projects and short-term
professional exchanges in the European
Union Belarus citizens
have already established contacts with
peers in EU Member States the visa
facilitation agreement will make Europe
even closer to Belarus citizens and we
hope that our ties beat economic
cultural on scientific will be further
strengthened and in Cannes according to
the common approach for the development
of EU policy on visa facilitation visa
facilitation agreement should not be
concluded without a readmission
agreement being tres that is why on 30
January 2014 ago she Asians were
formally open to with the Republic of
Boris on the agreement concerning the
readmission of persons presiding without
authorization we have already been
cooperating well in the field of
readmission the signature of this
agreement will allow us to continue our
good cooperation on readmission issues
and to ensure that we have rapid and
effective procedures for the
identification and safe and orderly
return of persons who have no right or
lower forever right to enter or stay on
territory of Belarus or one of the EU
member states this agreement will also
help to facilitate the transit of such
persons in a spirit of cooperation over
the past three years there has been
remarkable progress in EU Belarus
relations notably through the Eastern
Partnership today signature of the two
agreements is a step further we look
forward to the conclusion of the
ratification process and the entry into
force of the agreements as soon as
possible once all conditions are met now
without further delay I would like to
give the floor first to Commissioner and
son and then to Minister Maki
thank you thank you very much to the
board we are here to today to celebrate
an important achievement our goals for
the EU Alpha bellos
negotiations of the visa facilitation
and readmission agreements between
Belarus and EU has been going on for
almost 66 years the texts we are signing
today are the culmination of all the
efforts made by our negotiators to
improve the mobility of our citizens in
a well-managed and secure environment
ultimately we are building closer links
and bridges in people-to-people connect
contacts enriching our societies and our
culture's further together with Eastern
Partnership countries for us already
mentioned by Minister bossanova CH once
the agreements entered into force it
will bring significant improvements the
visa fee will be reduced to 35 euros the
deadline for counsel to consul Tate's to
take a decision on a visa application
will be shortened a number of categories
of applicants will be entitled to
receive multiple entry visas with
increasingly longer valid valid validity
while having to submit less supporting
documents to prove their purpose or
charge
as for readmission return statistics
shows that there is already very good
cooperation between Belarus and the EU
Member States I'm happy about this the
agreement of today puts the work of the
competent authorities in charge or to
readmission in a precise framework to
ensure orderly and safe return of the
regular migrants at Belarus request a
two-year transitional period was agreed
for the implementation of the provisions
concerning their admit readmission of
third country nationals and stateless
persons this will provide Belarus more
time to get ready for the full
implementation of the readmission
agreement with the support of EU our
cooperation will be further enhanced by
the regular meetings of the joint
readmission and
facilitation committees set up by both
age by both agreements both agreements
will enter into force simultaneously
once both Belarus and the EU have will
have completed our respective internal
procedures for ratification as you know
this means first receiving the consent
of the of the European Parliament and
the ratification of the Belarus National
Assembly with the entry into force will
be able to start benefiting from the
facilitation provided for by the visa
person facilitation agreement I am glad
to be here today to celebrate this
historical day for our bilateral
relationships and I wish to thank
Belarus sooner efforts and willingness
to reach agreement I look forward to
continue our cooperation and strengthen
the ties between the European Union and
Belarus citizens madam commissioner mr.
Deputy Prime Minister in a minute we
will finally put out put our signatures
under the Belarus EU visible simulation
and admission agreements and this event
will mark an end of almost as it was
mentioned here six years of intense
negotiations it is a long anticipated
landmark accomplishment in Belarus EU
dialogue cooperation in fact Belarus was
ready to side this agreement since
September last year following a relevant
decision of the president of Belarus
this was I must say not an easy decision
given the additional challenges posed by
own admission commitments at the same
time the president expressed his
approval already at that point due to
the benefits of visa facilitation for
the mobility of the routine citizens I
am sure that signing of these agreements
will contribute to the development of
the civil society of the reserve this is
important for both paths there ruse as
it was mentioned here is a world leader
in terms of Schengen visas per capita in
that light we wanted to make every
possible step to conclude the agreements
as early as possible in 2019
to allow their enter into force before
the new you physically
unfortunately we are not able to make
use of this opportunity due to different
reasons as a result on 2nd February 2020
the price of fur or shouldn't gain
business for dolls and citizens will
rise to 80 euro it is not something that
we were working for the initiative
should not be the ones to pay for this
delay when flagging the agreements we
kindly call on the European Union and
its member states to examine every
option available in the EU a quiz
- temporary freeze the price of Schengen
business for the Aleutians - 60 euro at
the same time we hope for concerted and
resilient efforts both in the US and in
the European Union to ensure the prompt
departmental approval of the agreements
so that they can enter into force as
soon as possible and I am happy that my
colleagues supported to support this
proposal without both of you I am
delighted to join my vulnerable products
for in sealing of these important
treaties and paving the way for the air
[Applause]
just
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]